all right he's going over the center
divider unit stay on the right side we
got it for you wrong side of the road a
routine delivery gone wrong when a
suspect apparently carjacks an amazon
truck and leads police on a high speed
chase
speeds around 45 miles per hour runway
almost tc due to a white car it happened
at about five o'clock monday evening in
riverside california when two separate
homeowners reported break-ins police say
the suspect later identified as quinn
jarnell larks then stole an amazon
delivery truck and drove off
here
already just
moderate tc on the freeway right there
police video shows the truck crashing
into a car on the 60 freeway and later
into two others
i just
really bad again into another truck
vehicle is going to be disabled
when the truck is seemingly stuck the
suspect jumps out of the vehicle and
makes a break for it he's hopping out of
the car going to go northbound across
the freeway we got him
after running across the freeway he
attempts to escape by climbing a highway
sound barrier wall just north of you
guys
it's only when he fails to get over the
wall that the suspect turns himself over
to police riverside officials say larks
was taken into custody and now faces
charges of attempted murder home
invasion robbery carjacking assault with
a deadly weapon reckless evading of
police and suspicion of dui of drugs
causing injury for the latest
developments in this story and all
things true crime stay with long crime
network i'm sierra gillespie